all right get your flashlights and
control panels ready because we just got
our first official teaser trailer for
Blum House's Five Nights at Freddy's
movie based on the wildly popular video
game series by the same name and this
looks to be nailing everything the fans
have been clamoring for obviously we're
gonna be going over everything in this
teaser small Easter eggs game references
cameos and where we think this story is
going to take things but also we're
going to be touching on some of the
leaks and what we've heard was featured
in that bigger trailer compared to this
first teaser but no worries we'll warn
you if there's any sort of borderline
spoilers coming up so with all of that
out of the way thank you so much for
clicking this I'm your host Jared now
let's get into Five Nights at Freddy's
so before we jump into the full
breakdown of this trailer I'm sure a lot
of people having a damn clue what Five
Nights at Freddy's is so here's just a
brief overview of what's going down so
Five Nights at Freddy's is based on a
video game series by the same name I'm
assuming this is kind of pulling mainly
from the first game but we'll see but
yeah let's focus on that where you play
as a lone security guard named Mike
Schmidt who's just started working at
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza think like a
nightmarish Chuck E cheese ShowBiz Pizza
or the one I grew up with the Pizza
Peddler
[Applause]
a thing of nightmares anywhere though
all of the animatronics are haunted
because their creator William Afton
unalived several children and their
Spirits now live in these machines now
each night they come alive with Mike
having to survive until the morning
using various monitors controls and
traps to ward off and avoid these
demented animatronics the previous Night
Guard guides Mike leaving behind kind of
voice memos and clues and if Mike is
caught before the morning the evil
animatronics try to horrifically stuff
his body into a spare animatronic suit
that's just laying around 2021's Willy's
Wonderland is uh I I don't know the
closest live-action interpretation of
this video game so far a good great
grand all caught up now let's get into
this actual trailer so everything opens
with what sounds like a voiceover of
Matthew Lillard's William Afton giving a
bit of the backstory of the rundown
restaurant saying how the owner isn't
ready to let things go as we can see a
closed sign leaning over the shape of
the Freddy Fazbear's pizza and in the
background we can also see the entrance
along with a still intact sign above it
now I'm wondering if we're going to be
getting some flashback sequences
sprinkled in throughout this movie as
Mike the security guard learns more
information about this joint or maybe a
cold open showing how things led to this
closure and the incidents with these
children speaking of Mike we see him
pull up to this pizza joint presumably
on his first night on the job Mike is
being played by Josh Hutcherson with the
character hopefully being fleshed out a
bit more than the games he's had a tough
past which obviously leads him to take
you know this sketchy job and also has
an inquisitive knack to him which means
he'll be digging into all of the clues
and the truth throughout this movie it
appears Mike though is not alone as he's
accompanied by a young girl now at first
first I thought that this might be his
daughter or something but then after
some more digging this is actually Abby
Schmidt his 10 year old sister played by
Piper Rubio it's mentioned that Mike had
to step in as more of a parent or
Guardian for Abby because their parents
went missing and she's kind of more uh
creative Brave and like Mike inquisitive
I kind of like that they're gonna
include more characters ramping up the
tension a bit more and having them
potentially in different areas of the
restaurant dealing with different
threats at the time but it sounds like
she's supposed to kind of just sit still
sleep color stay out of the way all of
that blah blah blah but you know damn
well with her being a little girl she's
gonna be the first to see the
animatronics move with Mike claiming
that it's just her imagination there's
some brief shots of the inside of the
restaurant as we get you know the
employee only door with it looking a bit
different from the games the edge of the
lit up Freddy Fazbear's Pizza sign which
again looks similar to the games and our
first look at Mike Schmidt who just he
honestly just looks like Josh Hutcherson
I can't tell from this shot but I'm
curious if they're slapping some blue
contacts in his eyes because the only
characteristic that we know from the
game about Mike is that he has blue eyes
and that's when he's jammed into the
animatronics in the game over screen in
the security room Mike is fiddling with
the power and we can see some of the
restaurant mascots in a grid on the door
behind him even the controls and monitor
layout are similar format to that of the
games with the training tape labeled mic
sitting on top of the VCR the training
video is very much that cheesy 80s 90s
tone a bit more upbeat and colorful than
the initial training tutorial from the
first game this appears to be cat Conor
Sterling's character slowly walking Mike
through the backstory of the brighter
days of Freddy Fazbear's pizza now I'm
really digging this because it's
painting the uneasy parallel of this fun
bright happy environment against the
dark scary current condition that it's
in the door buzzer is a heavier much
more industrial version than the way
that it sounds in the games when the
door lights are buzzing and were
introduced to yet another character from
The Five Nights at Freddy's lore Vanessa
played by Elizabeth Leo and it looks
like they they might be twisting the
lore a little bit with this character
because in Five Nights at Freddy's help
wanted she was the main protagonist as a
security guard whereas here it appears
that she's more of a police officer with
her alluding to knowing about them aka
the animatronics so I'm wondering if
they're baking it in here that she's
already kind of investigated these
things and is somewhat going to be more
of a mentor to Mike's character there's
drawings on the fridge which I'm
assuming Abby draws at some point
showing us Freddy Bonnie Chica foxy
along with some of the ghost children
which I'm guessing that Abby saw and
Mike just doesn't believe her at all
because the children's eyes and Sinister
Smiles tell me these aren't the same
happy ones from that show up in the
training video again I'm saying Abby
warns Mike with Mike just brushing it
off as childhood nonsense until he
starts to investigate things which looks
like to be the case here until he does
what he's not instructed to and of
course falls asleep obviously this is a
big old No-No and causes everything to
go Haywire with Mike's security monitors
glitching out similarly to the security
breach alert and so forth but as the
glitch event is happening hardcore fans
may catch the song playing on the
intercom system the march of the
toridors which is a much more bombastic
version than the version that is played
on the music box when the power goes off
and Freddie is near
[Music]
there's some more glimpses of the
abandoned Pizza Joint along with our
very first look at the full-scale
animatronics of Freddy and his crew and
obviously these dudes look great front
man Freddy chica with the cupcake and
let's eat bib looks perfect and Bonnie
with their guitar and a big old
malfunction appears to happen with Mike
throwing the power this is where all of
the hardcore fans will go bananas
because Mike flips through all of the
security monitors similar to that of the
game but the same March of the Tory
doors plays with a much more cartoony
almost carnival-like tone to each of the
notes which I gotta say really adds to
the overall creepiness of this trailer
as Vanessa fills in Mike about all of
the missing children and the history and
the building of the animatronics I gotta
say if you're barely showing the kids
being kidnapped or snatched up via
Silhouettes makes it feel like the
viewers we the viewers are also watching
through security monitors quickly
switching between cameras stopping like
wait what did did you see that it also
looks like Abby will be exploring the
building while Mike is working and
she'll be the one that first stumbles
upon the ghost children and can kind of
see the children running away just
disappearing Into Thin Air so the
sequence is bound found to happen before
the fridge painting that we saw earlier
I'm betting our initial tour of Freddy's
you know Pizza Joint will be Through The
Eyes of her and then a nice homage to
the jump scare game over screen as we
can see the animatronics eyes in the
otherwise dark Corridor hella creepy for
sure it almost looks like there will be
some time jumps like I mentioned earlier
as there's this group of four adults
that I'm assuming are aggressively
breaking into the rundown pizza place to
find their missing children or at least
clues about them if so they are
definitely fleshing out the backstory
and lore surrounding the haunted
animatronics a bit more and each of the
kids in the haunted animatronics are
going to eliminate these adults which I
think flashbacks are probably the way to
go in this movie the creepy thing is
though some of this looks to be taking
place outside of the pizza joint which
I'm wondering if in fact this will take
place you know over multiple shifts you
know with Mike where night one he learns
of the tutorials night two weird things
start to happen night 3 Vanessa shows up
filling Mike in about the backstory and
so forth because Mike is clearly
exploring some sort of wooded area with
a symbol of a rabbit being drawn in the
dirt potentially referencing Bonnie or
maybe even springtrap uh from the looks
of it later in this trailer the visuals
of the four missing children here
surprisingly share characteristics to
each of the animatronics that they later
possess starting from the right or I
guess the left of the screen the boy is
wearing bunny ears and a purple shirt
referencing Bonnie the rabbit next is
the orange shirt with what looks like a
hook for a hand and of course is
referencing foxy tying in with more of
the pirate-like characteristics the next
kid is wearing a similar hat to the
front man Freddy wears in the band and
lastly the little girl has the same
color palette as chica with her shirt
almost kind of looking like a bib now
who knows if this is why the
animatronics have these features or if
it's just just a cool characteristic
choice either way this is our main four
from the first game anyway it sounds and
looks like the main goal of the
animatronics seems to be capturing Abby
and having her join the ranks of the
other four haunted children and with the
drawing showcasing that five children
are holding hands with a larger bunny I
have a feeling that this bunny is in
fact referencing springtrap that we
again see later in this trailer and of
course if you know your Friday is lore
this one is a resurrected form of
William Afton so it looks like this will
be how they uh Implement Matthew
Lillard's character a little bit more
into the story and I'm sure that we'll
get some backstory on him and why he
eventually goes mad but yeah this bunny
drawing combined with the fifth
animatronic spells this out so the
writers are definitely a pizza pick and
not cherry picking pieces of lore here
from you know the different various
games not just the first game here Mike
looks to be caught similar to the games
where one of the animatronics pops out
and give gives like a player a game over
screen but instead is trapped to a chair
in some sort of a torture device now I'm
curious if this is newer stuff added
combined with the sister location
animatronic features from that game
because each of those I guess has been
said to have child luring features to
them and the grinding gears could also
be how those children perished either
way I like how the visuals mirror the
game and also are separating itself the
trailer pretty much ends with quick
flashes of events a child being driven
away which I'm assuming is a memory of
Mike as a child Vanessa seems to be in
the hospital with Mike by her side so
she'll no doubt be attacked during one
of the nights and then Mike will have to
be you know fending off things by
himself it looks like some flashbacks to
Mike beating someone up in a fountain
maybe this explains his backstory and
why he had to take this job to begin
with along with springtrap who again
sounds like it's being voiced by Matthew
Lillard's character and tracking Abby
now the final bit of this is a nice
Easter egg to fans as the taxi driver is
a cameo from YouTuber Corey X Kenshin
who of course is a big fan of the
franchise streaming it helping it grow
to the cult following that it does have
now there's also been rumor of
Markiplier who is in the same similar
situation making a cameo but we'll see
if that's the case when the final film
comes out before we wrap up I just
wanted to talk about some of the
spoilers from the Freddy's games that
could potentially be part of the story
in this movie so uh this is uh your
spoiler warning check the monitors you
don't want to have a jump scare of
spoilers okay so in the later games it's
implied that Mike Schmidt is actually
the son of the evil animatronics Creator
William Afton and part of me thinks that
they are going this route with this
movie with Mike having kind of a cloudy
past maybe he doesn't remember things
unable to remember his parents
specifically his father and this is why
springtrap aka William Afton or is
Transcendence form wants Abby because
she is theoretically and actually I
guess his daughter so yeah from this
trailer it looks like they are going to
be pulling a whole Star Wars Empire
Strikes Back Mike I am your father type
of bomb in the third Act of this movie
it would be a great twist but uh hey
we'll we'll see anyway that is
everything about Five Nights at Freddy's
all jam-packed and in this first trailer
please let me know how much I missed
because uh I've only watched Friends
play through these games so my first
hand experience is very limited but yeah
what uh are you most excited about and
what small details and Easter eggs do
you hope make the final movie let us
know anything and everything in the
comments below if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there click one clickety clack check the
monitors and click one but with all of
that out of the way thank you so much
for your constant support I've been
Jared I'll see in the next one take care
and peace